[Music]
welcome to the 2023 Crunchyroll anime
Awards the best celebration of anime for
fans and creators we're Tim Liu and
Lauren Moore of Crunchyroll and we're
here in Tokyo at the Grand Prince Hotel
new Takanawa to share a few special
announcements and additional Awards
exclusively for you our live stream
viewers at home before the main show
kicks off in just a few moments things
have just wrapped up on the orange
carpet and will be heading over to the
main stage shortly where our guests are
taking their seats as we speak we have
an incredible show in store for you
tonight this is the seventh annual anime
Awards presented by Crunchyroll but
notably it's our first time bringing the
event here to Japan we'll finally get to
honor our favorite creators and talent
in person and see the next up their
Awards on stage tonight thank you to
everyone who submitted millions of votes
to help honor the best of the best in
anime we'd love to know where you're
watching from tonight so let us know in
the chat yeah so uh we are streaming
live on YouTube and twitch and I know
there's a bunch of you guys co-streaming
as well so shouts out to everyone
joining us right now where are you guys
watching from specifically right now
where are you guys uh Texas Texas anyone
in Texas where Lauren's at right now Bay
Area anybody from the bay
stems area yeah how about how about our
homelands our homelands anyone watching
from the Caribbean Korean hey I don't
think so Australia how about Australia
Sydney Parramatta New South Parramatta
New South Wales anybody anybody nope
let's keep moving on all right before
our host Sally amaki and John kabira
take the main stage let's jump straight
into some special Awards and like all
other anime Awards these were voted on
by official judges
and you the fans Lauren are you ready
let's do this let's begin all right
first up the category that brought us
heart tugging characters this year from
adorable espers to Tiny resilient
members of the Shadow Clan the must
protect at all costs character and I
know people feel very strongly about
this one on people he's people and the
anime award goes to
Anya forger from Spy family by wit
studio and cloverworks
up next the parts of an anime that can
set the tone for the entire season we're
excited to announce the anime awards for
the best opening and ending sequences so
for best opening sequence the anime
award goes to
the rumbling by SIM from Attack on Titan
final season part two mapa
for best ending sequence the anime award
goes to Comedy by gen hoshino from Spy
family with studio and cloverworks
next announcing the awards for best
voice artist performance to incredible
Talent across the following languages
for the best voice artist performance in
Japanese the winner is
yukikaji as adding yega in Attack on
Titan final season part two mapa
and for the best voice artist
performance in English the winner is
Zach Aguilar as David Martinez in
cyberpunk Edge Runners trigger
for best voice artist performance in
Castilian the winner is
Jaime Perez de Sevilla as Utah mapa
continuing the awards for amazing
performances across different languages
four best voice artist performance in
French the winner is silent drum roll
please
Bridget lacordier as Bocce in the
ranking of Kings with Studio
for best voice artist performance in
German the winner is Nicholas artagio as
Utah kotsu in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen zero mapa
four best voice artist performance in
Portuguese the winner is Nina Cavallo as
Anya forger in spy family with studio
and clover works waku waku
4 best voice artist performance in
Spanish the winner is
Alejandro orsco as utaro in Demon Slayer
kimetsuno yaiba Entertainment District
Arc UFO table
four best voice artist performance in
Arabic the winner is
Madhouse
four best voice artist performance in
Italian the winner is Elisa Giorgio as
Maki zenen in Jiu Jitsu kaisen core one
mapa
big congratulations to all the winners
so far yeah seriously a lot of talent
right there really really cool and if
you're just joining us we are here in
Tokyo for the Crunchyroll anime Awards
where the main show is just moments away
we're Tim and Lauren from Crunchyroll
and we're sharing some special Awards
directly to you our live stream viewers
as our event guests take their seats now
before we deliver our next set of awards
Crunchyroll games and Capcom have an
exclusive announcement for Street
Fighter duel right now fans are
collecting over 40 fan favorite
characters and fighting it out in the
franchise's first ever mobile RPG on IOS
and Android now a new fighter and boss
is on the way in a monster-sized
collaboration let's take a look
[Music]
thank you
oh can't wait to play that now enough
about games let's get back to the anime
Awards go the best drama category has a
huge range we're honoring anime that
took us from a four-year-old living
alone at home to a body mod obsessed
cyberpunk City the anime award for the
best drama ghost 2.
Attack on Titan final season part two
mapa
we're celebrating the action anime that
changed the game this year the best of
the best in fights chases and high
adrenaline moments hoo-ha that kept us
at the edge of our seats four best
action the anime award goes to
Demon Slayer kemetsuno yaiba
Entertainment District Arc UFO table
oh a huge congratulations from
Crunchyroll and anime fans
worldwide and finally before we head to
the main stage the awards for best
supporting character best main character
and best new series selected by our
judges along with you the fans so for
best supporting character the anime
award goes to
Anya forger in spy family with studio
and cloverworks
next the best main character and the
anime award goes to
Erin Jaeger in Attack on Titan final
season part two mapa
and without further Ado here is the best
new series and the anime award goes to
spy family with studio and cloverworks
what a great first season
congratulations to all of our winners
thank you all at home for voting the
full list of winners will be available
on crunchyroll.com after the show wraps
up and we actually have one more special
announcement for you at home I am very
excited to share some big news on behalf
of Crunchyroll in partnership with Sony
Music Entertainment Japan Crunchyroll
has added music to our service providing
even more content for subscribers the
content is rolling out on the service
right now you can search for iconic
anime Jason artists including Lisa amen
hiroyuki sawano and many more we have
over 3 000 videos including full-length
concerts and music videos as well as
artist pages so please enjoy your music
along with your anime on Crunchyroll and
let us know what you think you'll like
it I like music I listen to music
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right Tim are you ready oh I'm ready
all right let's head inside where our
industry guests are ready for our hosts
acclaimed TV presenter John kabira and
actress singer and member of nanobun
Noni Juni saliamaki to everyone watching
from home thank you for joining us the
seventh annual Crunchyroll anime Awards
is about to begin
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
accepted as who I am authentically Holy
as myself
anime has changed my life by just giving
me more confidence especially as someone
who is a very much a Wallflower growing
up when I was little I grew up with a
very strict family and it made me kind
of feel like I couldn't be myself once I
was able to go to conventions was when I
realized that I don't have to pretend to
be anything I could just be myself and
cons the most important thing that anime
means to me is love
is yeah
storytelling is amazing I really do
appreciate the um artist and the makers
the plots there's really touching
moments in anime that make it seem so
relatable it gives you something that
you don't get from reality television
it's just a beautiful thing to see and I
wouldn't trade it for anything in the
world anime is going to keep on going
and I don't care if I'm 90 years old I'm
still being watching it and my grandkids
gonna watch it kids grow up and be happy
they can love what we love growing up
you couldn't ask for anything more than
this
anime means
New Beginnings I'm going to be an anime
fan for life
[Music]
I will always love anime we anime are
together forever
thank you anime gracias anime
[Music]
hello everybody I'm Sally omaki I'm so
thrilled to be here with John covered up
with this fantastic salute to the anime
fans the pleasure is all mine thank you
so much
to see you all
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone
a big welcome to all the fans watching
out there around the globe we are so
excited
for the first time ever we are bringing
you the anime awards from Japan
we are here at the Grand Prince Hotel
shintakanawa where we've achieved
something unprecedented
tonight we've gathered some of the
biggest names in anime in one room
the world has changed so much over the
last few years so no more than ever it's
vitally important that the creators and
artists who dream up so many of our
favorite anime understands
the influence they have on the fans
around the world and how much they've
done to brighten people's lives
like so many of you anime is an
important part of my life and being a
big fan myself I'm honored to be a part
of this thriving Community the people
presenting the awards tonight are stars
from all over the world and all walks of
life from athletes to actors Mega
influencers to Major directors to
Comedians and content creators everyone
here tonight considers themselves huge
anime fans and are ready to celebrate
this year creators have reached new
levels of their incredible Talent so let
me tell you
determining the recipients of each award
was no easy feat
no it wasn't
I'm certainly glad it wasn't up to me
I should need anime fans from all over
the world voted for their favorites
18 million votes were cast Over All and
determined the grand winners
okay so let's get to the reason we are
all here tonight
celebrating the anime that has inspired
thrilled entertained and completely
World us this year
let's kick off this big night with
someone who has always supported the
anime industry and the Arts of
Storytelling
no one knows how important it is to
change hearts and Minds through the
power of creativity and Technology more
than the chairman president and CEO of
Sony group Corporation Mr kenichiro
Yoshida
[Music]
thank you
good evening everyone
I'm kenichiro Yoshida CEO of Sony group
welcome to the 2023 Crunchyroll anime
Awards
this year marks the seventh year of this
award that honors the achievements of
anime works and creators through voting
of anime fans many of the stories and
characters that evoke empathy including
more than 50 TV and Theatrical titles by
over 30 Studios selected for these
awards were born here in Japan
we are thrilled and honored to be able
to host a global celebration of anime
here in Japan with our creators our fans
who are joining the Randy Rose live
stream and our partners who are here
with us tonight
has become an entertainment with a
global cultural Force
currently
nearly
300 million fans around the world are
enjoying anime on streaming services
this is nearly double to what it was two
years ago and the anime fan communities
are growing at this very moment
add Crunchyroll
we are also contributing to spreading
the condo emotions of anime to the world
together with our partners
entertainment has the power to connect
people and we feel that there is social
significance in expanding handles
but this is not possible without the
passionate people behind anime
I would like to express my sincere
respect for the creative Community who
lead us to the world of dreams that
exceed our imagination and give us the
pleasure of experiencing them
and lastly this award is only possible
because of the fans who have voted in
over 200 countries and regions
we would like to thank each and every
one of you for your wholehearted support
your energy is our driving force to
expand the condo of anime
I feel extremely grateful to be able to
share the magnificence of anime with
everyone tonight thank you very much
please enjoy the show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
such inspiring words for tonight okay
that's in your seat belts it's time for
our first award the presenter is an
Entertainer an entrepreneur and when it
comes to anime there is no way around it
if you've watched his YouTube channel
you already know he is definitely a
super fan
here to present the award for best
original anime
please welcome the one and only Roland
[Music]
thank you very much for coming to here I
hope I'll have a good time and enjoy
drinking together
hello everyone in Japan and around the
globe my name is Roland
you may be wondering why I'm here
I love anime and I
disguised myself and appeared in
Akihabara
and I love very original anime stories
it is my honor to be presenting the
original best anime award
s here are the nominees for best
original anime
original animation best original anime
foreign
[Music]
deco
foreign
[Music]
healer girl
happy
the award winner is within my hand okay
let me take my time to open up this
envelope
and the anime award goes to
decrease
licorice recoil
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
congratulations
I never expected that to for me to be
standing here in front of you I was not
mentally ready but I'm very excited so
you know the competition competitor
candidates are so strong and a very good
work as well
so so I'd like to uh say thank you to
all the judges and the people on the
jury
and when it comes to the original anime
what you have to do is to start from
zero and it is so stressful and very
competitive
no matter what you work you do no you do
from scratch and you do it over over
again
and that would give that is a very good
experience and then very good
opportunity for any Creator any people
involved in anime especially the
original anime
so I really hope that there will be a
movement in which that people support
those and creators of the original anime
and grow them thank you
to present the award for best character
design is a very talented actress and a
member of the top either group 46.
please welcome
[Music]
when it comes to your anime the most
inspiring characters are the ones that
are so unique that you can recognize
them immediately just from a smaller
detail
maybe it's their posture their smirk and
iconic hairstyle or they unmistakable
way they read their weapon just one look
at how they are drawn and you
immediately understand their full story
that's the gift of great artistry
here are the minutes for a best
character design
best character design
s
cyberpunk Edge runners
okay what roses
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure Stone ocean
[Music]
spy family
spy family huh
[Music]
done
ranking of Kings
Bootsy
[Music]
Demon Slayer
Entertainment District dark
[Applause]
my dress up darling
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm not really used to
standing in front of you like this great
audience
my name is
foreign
and all those characters are very
beautiful
and they are facial expressions and
Artistry works
and every details are so carefully
designed
it is not only beautiful
but also
you can see the spirit
and personalities of each character and
that's the reason why we are standing
here today
so it is a very small greetings but uh
that's it from me so I'm a voice actor
and so I'm not really
involved in animation
[Music]
therapy onto the people thank you
thank you
[Music]
animations to present Award for best
animation is a comic actor who has
played so many over our favorite anime
characters that when we hear his voice
we don't know if he will we should laugh
or fight him in an epic battle
please welcome Kendall Kobayashi
[Music]
hello
animation is a modern drawing or
painting it's a picture of feast for the
eyes no matter what the style is the
rules of the real world can be broken
and put back together in Wise never
imagined
all the great creators in this room know
that great leap's word in Innovation and
Visually stunning art history only
happen when someone takes a big risk and
tonight proves that taking big risks
earns a bigger rewards not only do they
gain a passionate fund following
worldwide but also the respect of
everyone in the anime Community here the
nominees for best animation animation
best animation
cyberpunk
cyberpunk Edge runners
Demon Slayer
Entertainment District Arc
[Music]
spy family
Attack on Titan final season part two
[Music]
ranking of Kings
foreign
[Music]
sir
well
they earned the anime award goes to
um
congratulations thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
and in the demonstrate here a franchise
we are planning to have World Tour
the two defense in Japan but outside of
Japan
and we are blessed with this opportunity
to turn me to raise a funds from the
world uh World outside of Japan
and they I visited France and Germany
recently and met the local funds
directory
and I'm sure that all those people I met
in those countries supported us and
helped us win this award
and their loyal support
not only their for the for us but also
the voice actors and all the people
involved in creation Nova animation I'm
going to pass this survey to my team
members thank you very much
[Music]
here to present the award for the best
continuing series please welcome to
Titans of American football professional
Street Aidan Hutchinson and JuJu Smith
[Applause]
here's the truth for everyone out there
athletes around the world love anime
we're huge fans
that's right nothing gets us more hyped
up for a game more why it's all about
those high octane fighting scenes
watching Warriors push the residence
overcome adversity and ultimately defeat
evil like when we play against you guys
foreign
I think you have that backwards our team
destroys like ninjas
well let's agree to disagree on that no
matter what sport you play I think we
can agree that athletes understand
discipline
um
and it takes an incredible amount of
discipline creativity effort and
planning to make one season of an anime
series that all the fans love so the
ability to continue this kind of
Excellence season after season is
something worthy of celebrating
is
it's like winning the big championship
game and then coming back next year and
winning it again
here are the nominees for best
continuing series
best continuing series
Attack on Titan final season part two
[Music]
Entertainment District dark
romanticama Love is War Ultra romantic
o
[Music]
Stone ocean JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
Stone ocean
foreign
one piece
[Music]
made in Abyss the Golden City of the
scorching Sun
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you very much
everyone this is incredible
uh I've been nominated many times but I
was never selected to be the winner but
uh our staff and our team members got
together to bring you the great story
one piece but um
the staff members and the actors
may not be
we may not have been expecting this
honor and this is a great encouragement
and
I I want to bring this great news to my
staff members and uh I want to expand
the fans of 1p so that they can
appreciate the great strength of the
story we continue to support this series
and thank you very much
[Music]
thank you
squishy
Valentine's Day was just a few weeks ago
but every day it's Valentine's Day when
you have love in your heart
let's keep the spirit of the holiday all
year long and by announcing the nominees
for best romance here to do that
she is a WWE Superstar and he is one of
the stars of Cobra Kai please welcome to
massive fans of anime
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
a truly great love story can Captivate
Us like nothing else when it comes to
romance these are the anime that remind
us that Love's flame can thaw the
coldest heart
is
oh
well here are the nominees for best
romance
is
[Music]
romantic
AMA Love is War Ultra romantic
[Music]
foreign
my dress up darling
[Music]
is not just a cutie
call of the night
foreign
[Music]
love after world domination
Comey can't communicate second series
[Music]
okay and the anime award goes to
cut Usama Love is War Ultra Romancing
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
foreign
award
s story
spread the Japanese romance Japanese
boys and girls dreams and how they
relate to each other
and then it was sometimes funny it was
sometimes sad it who is filled with
drama and
um our work to execute the stories
guided us
with character building and the staff
members worked very hard to create this
amazing story
and as creators
our passion to this story I thank you
all my members and our great fans but
thank you to you all for supporting us
[Music]
we're coming up
on the fire from Attack on Titan final
season part two and it move hard
presents the award for best
and more when the 2023 24 anime Awards
returns
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s together for a special musical
performance here to commemorate the Dark
Fantasy Attack on Titan final season and
season 1's achievement of anime of the
year at Crunchyroll anime Awards 2022
this is Kota Yamamoto performing the
score that you can compose and she's on
the Fire
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
as you have seen
is not just a celebration of all the
incredible creators of anime but also
the Army your favorite fans across the
world
wreath and dream anime funds who
energize this world with their loyalty
and lovely heart from I'm so sorry I
probably I didn't go through so smoothly
but everyone
we visit a few anime friends
foreign
[Music]
this is
where to present the award for the best
fantasy
from the new anime film goodbye Don
Greece
and from the worldwide
stranger things
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
uh we have a saying in our family
brothers who watch anime together talk
about anime so much that it's genuinely
concerning
hi
there is
yeah I don't think that's a saying but
it's definitely the truth and when we're
not binging and bonding over anime we're
recruiting new fans we're always ready
to recommend our favorites
is
no storyline is too outlandish no
setting is too surreal creators have us
in the palm of their hands and that's
why we love it so much
foreign
from magical kingdoms to the lands of
demons and vampires here are the
nominees for best fantasy
fantasies
[Music]
ranking of Kings
made in Abyss the Golden City of the
scorching Sun
[Music]
Demon Slayer
Entertainment District dark
[Music]
Overlord four
ship
the case study of vanities
[Music]
[Applause]
jobless reincarnation season one second
core
[Music]
and the anime award goes too
Demon Slayer
Entertainment District art
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
for me to step up to the stage and I'm
thinking about what I should talk to you
now
basketball
anime fans from all over the world thank
you very much for casting about for him
demonstrated
yeah
so I think that this is uh that you
wrote of it
really move the paper all over the world
and if no we talked about the stories
about the people's connections and
relationships and bonds between the
characters and also the strengths of
heart
and I think that probably conveyed a
message about you know the importance of
living your life thank you very much
[Music]
foreign
best comedy please welcome back Kendall
Kobayashi
[Music]
so hello everyone again
great anime Shimmer is like a bad Clan
it doesn't matter who you are where you
live or what language you speak it
affects us all the same way and
sometimes all day
but unlike bad clumps will God read her
the humor and ask for more afterwards
those outstanding anniversaries we
celebrate tonight are University funny
so it's only appropriate that in the
whole world
here are the nominees for the best
comedies
spy family
[Music]
so cool
romantic
AMA Love is War Ultra romantic
Uncle from another world
[Music]
he call me
a boy kangming
my dress up darling
kotaro lives alone
[Music]
goes to
spider
bye family
[Music]
[Applause]
I live in Tokyo but I don't meet
these famous people so often this is a
great honor
so it's about our story
this is a Comedy Award that we've got
and people all around the globe voted
for our story I I I'm not so experienced
with comedy building but thanks to your
support
um we were able to build this story
and this is a unique
um work that we do and and
we enjoy it and I'm actually a bit
nervous on this big stage and uh
I'm quite a bit older and I think this
might be the peak of my career but thank
you very much for this memorable moment
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
Straight Ahead
performs a hit song from Demon Slayer
kimetano yaiban Entertainment District
park
and we will take home the anime Award
for best score plus under Schaefer
Robert Rodriguez Justin Lin
Valley Karen and sikuno and more
this is the 2023 Crunchyroll anime
Awards
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now from one of the most
popular manga of all time to a
juggernaut anime series film and fan
favorite
Slayer has taken the World by storm
here to perform the special version of
homura the hit theme song to Demon
Slayer the movie begin training please
welcome famed composer you give kazira
[Music]
sir
[Applause]
[Music]
don't forget
[Applause]
[Music]
Pikachu
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
a morning
[Music]
heavy
having a good night again
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go
[Music]
to the machine
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't believe
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
you know
foreign
[Music]
Oklahoma
foreign
[Music]
anime
is
[Music]
our next presenter is such a huge fan of
anime she inspired the producers to make
her character in the hit show Euphoria a
big anime fan soon
foreign
Bell and she cannot be seen starring in
the highly anticipated film The Hunger
Games The Ballad of song birds and
snakes joining us remotely to announce
the award for best score here is actress
and artist Hunters everyone and a big
hello to all the anime fans all around
the world I wish I could be there in
person but I am thrilled that I can at
least be with you virtually to present
this next award which combines two
things I admire anime and music a good
musical score can enhance a story drive
a narrative heightened emotion and in
some cases tell you how you should feel
the nominees for best score are
the best score
final season
Attack on Titan final season part two
foreign
Entertainment District Arc
[Music]
s
cyberpunk Edge runners
[Applause]
[Music]
spy family
foreign
[Music]
made in Abyss the Golden City of the
scorching Sun
[Music]
oh my God
your boy Kang me
[Music]
LLY read the truth
thank you
in the anime award goes to
Attack on Titan final season part two
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for introducing us
we are my name is
who I was in charge of the uh
the scoring creating the music for this
our final series
I was not expecting to receive this
award at all and I'm so surprised and I
was wondering if I'm actually still in a
dream or it is it is a reality
a few days ago that the final Seas
complete version was a broadcast
actually it was yesterday and I looked
at the animation yesterday I really
thought it was a really the result of
the hard work of all the people involved
and I miss I'm so honored to be part of
that effort
and I directed this take this
opportunity to extend my thanks to all
the people who have supported us
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
you present the best anime songs
please welcome back lalina Vega
[Music]
[Applause]
any WWE Superstar knows the importance
of a good entrance song it not only has
to get the crowd riled up but it also
has to set expectations for who's coming
out and the kind of chaos that's about
to happen
music sets the mood and it has that
exact same important job in anime
news
a good song enhances all the action it
ties the entire experience together it
gets in your brain and if it's a really
good song you don't mind that it lives
there permanently
again
I'm honored to present the nominees for
best anime song
foreign
[Music]
the numbering
final season part of two the rumbling
Sim Attack on Titan final season part
two
[Applause]
[Music]
kick it pushing again
spy family comedy gen hoshino spy family
[Music]
my non-fiction
romantic my non-fiction
Love is War Ultra romantic
[Music]
shall we dance
second season
Shadows house second season
let me give
[Music]
and the anime award goes to Jose
the rumbling sin Attack on Titan final
season part two
[Applause]
[Music]
the winner couldn't be here tonight but
we notified him earlier that he received
this award
and he has graciously accepted and asked
John kibera to read this message on his
behalf is
[Music]
[Applause]
standing sir I'm so dead congratulations
thank you
so you they asked me to read his message
right I just wanted to make sure thank
you
well I'm so nervous
arigato
thank you very much crunch roll
and all the fans who have been
supporting us thank you
I'm very very sorry that I couldn't be
with you today but I'm so honored to
have received this fantastic award
in 2022 there are so many Fantastic
anime songs released and on the 10th of
January in the rumbling was released and
it actually created huge impact and it
left the ongoing memory or a mark in
your memory I'm so honored but actually
I could create this music because of
this fantastic Attack on Titan animation
great animation
so
the creator of Attack on Titan I'd like
to extend my heartfelt respect to him
and also last three I just have to say
this to you
Sim is a rock and roll band
and please come to your concert the live
concert we are planning to visit a lot
of different countries in the world uh
this year so please come to see our life
because sad thank you
[Applause]
so let me go back to put on my moderate
as a hat
now
here to present a word for the best film
is the climbed actor of so many of our
favorite movies and shows sour Suzuki
[Music]
[Applause]
crunchy
an email address
crunchy world the anime Awards 2023
being held in Japan congratulations my
name is Sarah Suzuki hi everyone
whether you're in a dark movie theater
or snuggled down in a comfort over your
couch a truly masterful film will sweep
you away to another world
these are these years normally it's her
best film
animation
s
Dragon Ball super superhero
[Music]
one Piece
Film red
[Applause]
thank you
oh
bubble
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
the dear King
[Music]
let me announce
zero
[Music]
[Applause]
motion
is here but I'm representing the whole
team
well thank you very much for this award
it's such an honor
I am a
very untouched and delighted
I'm from Toho
my name is
I am one of the producers for this great
story
the fans all over the world
are
enthusiastic about this film and very
supportive I appreciate you all
created the original story
and then
focused their skills and expertise
with the help of creators and staff and
um
artists artists
to create a fantastic film
and then the publisher situation
supported us
film making committee and other
stakeholders
committed themselves
I feel happy
to announce that the TV series will be
will begin soon so we want to
keep pleasing our fans all over the
world I appreciate your continued
support
[Applause]
[Music]
Ali is here with a special guest aklo to
perform their singles Lost In Paradise
from Juju to Kaizen plus the awards for
best director and handmade we are on the
2023 Crunchyroll anime Awards
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I had a lot of uh traumatic things when
I was a child and in different animes
I've seen some of those things come up
that don't always come up and um just
television or movies when I was growing
up I was very small and it just showed
me that that was okay it's okay to be
that way it's okay to be me I'm a father
and uh and it's brought myself and my
son together on levels that I never had
with my parents
it's changed a lot of things from when I
was small so yeah because all the
protagonists all the antagonists are
always different they're always
multi-levels to them so I'm actually
here with a friend group that is
completely about anime and that's we're
all here from all different locations
it's done a lot for every relationship
that I've ever had the thing that I love
most about anime is how inviting and
welcoming it is to everyone you can find
yourself in a character in an anime
somewhere some anime has a character
that is exactly like you who feels the
same emotions that you feel you don't
find that in a lot of other platforms
[Music]
his film
excuse me
my contact lens fell off from my left
eye
uh
I cannot read my Instagram very well
[Applause]
[Music]
the strongest character in the anime
with his or her one eye they
can read better so when following their
examples I'm going to close my one eye
for those of you
my left contacts just fell straight out
of my eye so I am going to close my eyes
like every other Samurai character in an
anime I deeply apologize
I think I can overcome this challenge
thanks to the anime characters
presenter
his film
that continues to energize passionate
anime fans everywhere to present the
awards for best director please welcome
robots with readings
[Music]
[Applause]
what a room to be in and thank you Ali
for the wonderful compliment right back
at you now everyone here has influenced
me and my work in so many ways and will
continue to inspire me long after
tonight is over
foreign
stepping right into an anime in a few
days that I've been here we've visited
amazing anime Studios talked with other
directors artists and Visionaries my
family and I we've done everything from
the moving Gundam in Yokohama to every
floor of the urobashi
foreign
this experience has been truly
exhilarating
just like these next nominees who have
created and invited us into such
enchanting an extraordinary worlds thank
you for energizing me and all the anime
fans out there
it's been the ride of a lifetime
subscribe
and here are the nominees for best
director
[Music]
Heroes
hiroyuki image cyberpunk Edge runners
spy family
[Music]
recoil
s
ranking of Kings
[Music]
Aki Demon Slayer kimitsuno yaiba
Entertainment District dark
[Music]
thank you
final season
Attack on Titan final season part two
foreign
go
[Music]
sh
Aki Demon Slayer
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much I'm sir
honored to have received it is a
fantastic abroad and so ideally you
should have invited staff members of a
youth Studio but those are staff members
are very busy we see a news a title or
be a franchise
so
I think uh the creators winning a world
is a very important thing and not only
the directors but also the character
design and also those are people who to
draw the background pictures and the
character pictures now everyone is
working together to create fantastic
work and the days also a platform to
show such fantastic anime films and
Anime works and then that is a crunchy
roll I have to take this opportunity to
extend my heart first thanks to the
opportunity to have shown our work and
also the staff members who have been
helping us throughout the journey thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]
I know
I'd like to take to take this
opportunity to praise the Savi because
she reads so ingenuity
let's hear it foreign
[Music]
thank you so much
thank you
before we present the last award over
the evening it's our pleasure to welcome
someone who is no stranger to Japan and
there was much of his inspiration from
the world of anime in his own creative
life
please welcome to the stage the
celebrated director of massive films
such as Star Treks and Beyond as well as
many of The Fast and Furious movies
including the fastest the Furious Tokyo
Drift writer producer Android character
Justin Lin
[Music]
good evening everyone I'm truly honored
to be part of the celebration tonight
especially since I've had the honor of
working with some of the most amazing
creators in this community
foreign
most people might know me from Big
Hollywood films but my roots are
actually from independent cinema and
where you're and when you're in the
Indie filmmaker you learn quickly that
through all the noise and obstacles
passion is the most important currency
for me that's why I feel such a kinship
with so many anime creators whose
commitment to the art was filled by
their passion for their characters and
the journey and because of that
commitment true trust in community is
built
I am humbled and inspired to be part of
this community the trust and respect
that is earned through shared experience
means everything it reminds me every day
that I sincerely thank you
Community now
and now without further Ado it's time to
find out who will receive the 2023 anime
of the Year Awards
thank you Justin
[Music]
yes
we've climbed to the top of the mountain
and come to the final award over the
night anime of the year
please welcome to wildly a popular
streamers and the collaborators in the
content house rubies
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we're honored to be here tonight to
present the award for anime of the year
we've celebrated so many gifted creators
tonight it truly is impossible to narrow
them down to just one
the votes have been counted and we had
millions of people weigh in on all of
our categories tonight each nominee is a
masterpiece in its own right
foreign
despite all of them being so good there
has to be a grand winner and it was up
to the fans to just to make the
difficult choice of choosing only one
is
this award goes to the show that set the
standard for the genre this year
towering over all the others as a
masterpiece of execution
is
here are the nominees for anime of the
year
of the year
spy family
[Music]
cyberpunk Edge runners
friends
Attack on Titan final season part two
all summer ranking ranking of Kings
[Music]
Demon Slayer
Entertainment District dark
[Music]
foreign licorice recoil
a
Korea
[Music]
and the anime award goes to yourself
cyberpunk Edge runners
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is
director and other staff members are not
here so let me represent my team
this is totally unexpected
oh yeah
game and all is cyberpunk
cyberpunk tree
and uh we this is a joint project and
the animal
company game company Japan and Poland
and two different companies into
different countries collaborated
and uh we we were serious we argued
sometimes that we never compromised
and I think that's why we were able to
get this award well I thank everyone who
were involved in this great journey and
thank you all uh the fans all over the
world thank you very much
business
thank you for making our first anime
Awards in Tokyo such a memorable night
I hope we did it
well thank you everyone here tonight in
this room the creators artists producers
musicians the studios all of you for
putting your hearts and souls into your
work and everything you've done for
anime
we look forward to everything
thank you very much
[Music]
we are excited about everything you will
be creating this year and in the future
and to our presenters and all the anime
fans around the world watching this
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
good night from Tokyo see you again in
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]